testing is emerging as one of the
biggest issues of the coronavirus
response so far
if you piece together what happened it's
clear that it was bureaucratic bungling
that caused the problem the president
who identified the problem and insisted
it was fixed and the private sector that
is now actually fixing it here's the
timeline in January China published the
genetic code that would enable a test to
be built within days the Germans had
built one the w8 show adopted it for
worldwide use the Australians built one
too and that one worked our CDC built
their own and it finally went out on
February the 6th about a month after the
German test but ours didn't work On
February the 12th it was recalled more
time went by University labs and the
private sector were begging to make a
test the FDA the Food and Drug
Administration said no finally at the
end of February once the president
intervened the red tape was swept away a
few days later he ordered an overhaul of
the testing approach and on Friday he
announced a testing partnership between
the government and the private sector
but who was responsible for the initial
delays which officials decided to not
use the available tests to block the
private sector was it this man dr. Han
head of the FDA or this man dr. Redfield
head of the CDC or both of them
we need the answer now and someone must
take responsibility if it's not you dr.
Han or you dr. Redfield tell us who it
was this is bureaucratic bungling of the
worst kind it's all very well to say
let's focus on the future but this is
what always happens in government the
civil servants who actually make the
decisions never take responsibility no
one is held accountable and so nothing
changes Jenna what do you make of it
well I think that President Trump
addressed this very directly when he
said that you know they were taking
decisive action and that the and the
vice president also said today that with
the FDA's a swift action and
unprecedented action that now there's a
high throughput for testing and I think
that we can and should focus on what
we're doing with the information that we
have as as we have it and so with
leadership the better form of wisdom and
discretion is using that making the best
decision that you can with the
information and resources that you have
at the time available and so that's what
I think president Trump is taking such
great and decisive action here in
leadership by exercising his wisdom and
discretion here by saying here's what
we're going to do and he's being fully
transparent with the American people by
holding these almost daily press
briefings and giving the information
directly to the American people so I
think we do I need answers but I think
that even more than that we need to
focus on the future and focus on what
the FDA and the CDC are doing at this
point in coordination with state and
local government and of course President
Trump was so brilliant to bring in the
private sector like you said because now
we're seeing that Walmart's and others
are able to have these tests that are
parking lots and we're truly coming
together as a full society to make sure
that we address this but it's not by
saying we have to have a localized and
centralized federal government but
rather we need to get everyone here
involved so that we can do just what
they do in American country right which
is what is happening I totally agree
with all of that but you've been very
kind to these bureaucrats who caused
this problem Matt Gaetz what do you
think I think we need to know who's
responsible for this and there needs to
be some accountability you have
highlighted what is a problem in
Washington throughout the enterprise of
government people inside the beltway
always want to draw more power to
Washington president Trump's natural
instra instinct is to unlock the
potential of our country to solve
problems which is why at the very
beginning when there was a log jam at
the CDC it was President Trump who
overruled whatever bureaucrat it was to
say no we need state-based labs
authorized for testing immediately that
allowed us to be able to bend down this
curve of potential increase in exposure
to the virus and so again whether it's
the economy or the environment or any
other issue the president's instinct is
to democratize power across the country
just moments ago in the debate you had
Joe Biden saying well he would do more
to federalize the response he would try
to seize more control inside Washington
DC but but leveraging our partnership
is far more effective strategy yeah I
agreed Lisa what's your take look I mean
if we're being honest this is the
biggest point of vulnerability for the
president is the the fact that we
haven't you know the slowness in testing
that is an issue for the president it's
important now that they're ramping up
the efforts and they're increasing the
ability to do testing that is a concern
and if you listen to people like doctor
foul chia said the biggest things that
we need to be doing right now are one
blocking sick people from getting into
the country which we've seen President
Trump take action with China as well as
Europe and the UK which he got criticism
for with China as well even from people
like Joe Biden who said it was
xenophobic and instead it was the right
move for him to do other countries
followed suit so that's important but
also mitigating the spread here in the
United States and in order to do that we
need to know who has it
so I think what is important that is
being done now is the drive through
testing if you look at MERS I think
almost half of the cases people got in
the hospitals so it's important to
separate people who are potentially sick
with drive-through testing then to put
them in hospitals and then get
additional people sick who don't have it
so I think that's a really important
stuff and should be ramped up across the
country as well no you see I couldn't
get anyone to bite on my cool foot to
name names and the bureaucracy the
people who did this
all right had fear let's leave it there